vsauce kevin here you may know
may 10th 2020 as children's day in the
maldives or
mother's day in mexico or bono's 60th
birthday or
the anniversary of serial killer john
wayne gacy's death
but on may 10 2020 australia had
a very serious question as a nation it
collectively needed to know
how many sides a circle has the answer
is a little more nuanced than it may
seem there's the easy math
answer the real life answer and the
answer that's
part hard math and part real life
listen the answer can be pretty
straightforward
if you're lazy or if you want to stick
to the most basic
math a polygon is a two-dimensional
shape on a plane
that has a defined number of sides or
actually
angles it's right in the name the greek
poluganon means
many angled triangle is a trigon
three angles tridekagon 13
angles and 13 sides but
how many angles does a circle have
well none really
is that a nun agon not a gun
zilchigan there aren't any points at
which
two lines make a vertex that can make it
a
monogon which euclidean geometry
categorizes
as a degenerate polygon because its
end points overlap but if you're just
looking at
a circle you aren't seeing any angles
you're
really just seeing one continuous
side there's there's the first answer a
circle has
one side the end right wrong
what is a side this is where it
gets tricky in math a side is really an
edge or a face depending on whether
we're working in two
or three dimensions but in real life a
side is
a side you refer to the left side of
your body or
the side of a ship or the outside and
inside of your house side in old english
pretty much
set the tone for how we think of the
word it meant the
left or right flank of a person but when
we think about what a side
is it's always relative to the whole
humans have bilateral symmetry so the
left of your body is a mirror image
of the right for the most part that
whole unit your
body means we can break it down into
relative sides and
have it make sense a side is about
position
relative to something greater like
a side dish of your meal is relative to
the main dish of the meal the
steak or whatever spaghetti hot dogs
you know what i mean you can't have the
port side of a ship without drawing a
mental line of symmetry lengthwise
in its center you can't talk about how
the inside of your thigh
hurts without silently differentiating
it
from the obvious outside of your leg or
let's talk about starfish look at a
starfish because that's
radial symmetry coming from the center
outward it's got ten faces with two on
each
arm but we say it has five sides and
each of those sides has a left side and
a right side so
it's got five sides or ten sides
depending on
how we're breaking it down it's
positional it's
directional it's relative but
we're supposed to be talking about
circles circles okay all right all right
well
now we've got at least one more answer a
circle's got
an inside and an outside two
totally legitimate sides but
that's probably wrong because what about
wheels wheels you've got a circle and
it's rolling on a flat surface between
gravity and friction
eventually it stops let's imagine a
wheel
as a perfect circle because it's a
perfect circle and the surface is
perfectly flat
the actual point of contact between the
two is
infinitesimal in size does that make the
point
of contact a side probably
and how many are there i could roll a
circle ten
thousand times and it's never gonna stop
in the exact
same place that suggests there are
infinite
signs just like the coast of the
continent that
feverishly wished for an answer to this
very question the coast of australia
is infinitely long don't believe me
you should imagine imagine measuring the
coastline of australia using a measuring
stick
20 kilometers long then you go back and
measure it with a one kilometer
measuring stick
the measurement would actually be
significantly longer because you're able
to capture
more detail in the twists and turns of
the coastline
if you did it by the meter even more
centimeter millimeter nanometer or
fentometer the
smaller your unit of measurement the
more you reduce the uncertainty
and increase that coastline
and if your unit of measurement can
become
infinitely small then how does the
coastline not become infinitely
large it's the same exact concept with
sides of a circle we've got an infinite
number of points at which a circle can
come to rest
as it's rolling on a plane and the only
limitation we have
is in our ability to measure it so
how many sides would it have if we could
count
the atoms or the electrons or the quarks
sorry australia but how many sides does
a circle have just
doesn't have a definitive answer
depending on how you look at the problem
a circle can have
no sides one side two sides
or infinite sides
so what side are you
on how many sides do you think a circle
has
let me know down below
in the bottom side of this video
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you